sans les insectes pollinisateurs notre
bol de salade serait bien vide il
contribue à la production des fruits et
des légumes en butinant les fleurs mais
ils sont de plus en plus menacés chacun
d'entre nous peut contribuer à les
sauvegarder même sur un petit balcon en
ville
vous êtes-vous déjà demandé combien de
fleurs une abeille doit butiner pour
produire un kilo de miel
ça représente plus de 16 millions de
fleurs qui ont dû être récoltés par les
abeilles pour se transformer en mienne
une abeille en dinant toute sa vie va
faire un huitième d'une cuillère à thé
de miel
et elle ne produisent pas que du miel
elles sont responsables d'une grande
partie de notre alimentation
souvent que une bouchée sur trois dans
notre assiette est relié au
pollinisateur avant de la pollinisation
par les insectes qu'est-ce qu'on aurait
par exemple ici qui existeraient pas si
on avait pas les pollinisateurs en fait
la majorité des légumes fruits qu'on a
présentement sans la pollinisation par
les insectes on n'aurait pas si beau
haricots croustillants là les tomates
par exemple on dit que c'est un plan
autofertile sont capables de se
fertiliser par eux-mêmes par contre le
fait qu'il y a des bourdons surtout qui
viennent les polliniser ça aide avoir
des plus belles tomates un plus grand
nombre de tomates ici donc on est des
milliers
les concombres ça c'est crucial aussi
alors que les poivrons et les aubergines
ben c'est elle aussi donc elles vont
être fertilisées par plein d'autres
types de paninisateurs même chose pour
les fruits j'imagine absolument surtout
nous en fruitiers ils fleurissent tout
au printemps sans compter tous les
petits fruits aussi qu'on va avoir en
début de saison dès qu'on est une envie
d'avoir un potager on devrait avoir le
réflexe aussi de dire ok il faut que je
nourrisse mes pollinisateurs qui vont
venir polliniser mon jardin
il y a une dizaine d'années on a
constaté que les abeilles étaient en
déclin mais elles Montréal a ainsi été
créé pour implanter des ruches en ville
une des raisons pour qu'on a commencé à
faire de l'apiculture en ville c'est
qu'on se disait waouh il y a de plus en
plus d'interdictions aux pesticides en
ville donc nous abeilles vont être mieux
ce qui est ce qui est vrai ce qu'on
avait pas pensé par exemple c'est que
beaucoup de fleurs en ville et c'est
100% l'alimentation des abeilles ce sont
les fleurs c'est le nectar et le pollen
des fleurs donc on rajoute de plus en
plus de ruches dans un environnement où
on rajoute pas nécessairement plus en
plus de fleurs il y a 375 espèces
d'abeilles au Québec seulement
sauvage et elle ne sont pas dans des
ruches une ruches en forme c'est environ
100000 abeilles et donc 100000 abeilles
dans une zone qui est déjà les
paninisateurs Indiennes les abeilles
sauvages avaient de la difficulté à se
nourrir et là on leur rajoute une forte
compétitrice qui est prête elle aussi à
manger beaucoup de fleurs pour faire son
miel on se dit on fait un stop sur créer
plus de ruches en ville on fait surtout
rajouter plus de fleurs et recréer un
équilibre entre le nombre d'abeilles et
le nombre de fleurs pour un jour
potentiellement faire ok c'est bon on
peut recommencer à mettre des ruches
miel Montréal et donc devenu polyflora
avec une toute nouvelle mission
promouvoir les fleurs mellifères quand
on dit qu'une fleur et militaire c'est
qu'elle contient du nectar et du pollen
en quantité intéressante pour les
abeilles
l'organisme depuis aménagé cinq jardins
dont son camp de base le jardin vitrine
du campus 1000 en plein cœur de la ville
on a tout un programme de verdissement
et notre plus gros programme qu'on
essaie de mettre de l'avancement
s'appelle gardien des pollinisateurs ou
justement on cherche des environnements
collectifs comme des institutions
éduquées éducatives telles que des
écoles ou même des parcs pour faire des
jardins vitrines
tous les mercredis ces jeunes du collège
du rocher se réunissent pour travailler
sur un projet de plate-bande chapeauter
par polyflora je tente de prendre des
parce qu'ils sont très petites et on n'a
pas envie d'en perdre et qu'est-ce que
tu sais là c'est de la lobélie cardinale
c'est une plante rouge dis pourquoi vous
avez choisi ces espèces là
particulièrement sévariétés ce sont des
espèces qui sont plus susceptibles
d'attirer les abeilles et les autres
pollinisateurs dans les jardins qui vont
permettre aussi qui sont aussi très
décoratives pour les personnes qui vont
vouloir y aller
donc on ne la sphère dans laquelle il se
passe toutes sortes de projets
pédagogiques puis en parallèle à ça on a
le jardin pour insectes pollinisateur
qu'on est en train de mettre en place
cette année eux on n'a pas planté encore
un an c'est beau hein
kerbère blanche savez-vous qu'est-ce que
ça va attirer comme un cercle les
plantes avec beaucoup de fleurs vont
attirer les papillons passer comme ça il
peut prendre du nectar et du pollen sans
se déplacer beaucoup puis j'imagine
qu'il est plus grande plante va attirer
des abeilles il y a vraiment un souci
chez les élèves de développement tout ce
qui est l'écologie le développement
durable l'alimentation aussi donc ils
ont vraiment ce souci là
[Musique]
tant que la ville est reste le royaume
du béton et du gazon ça va être un
problème alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait en
plan du stress juste avoir des pelouses
plus écologiques laissez pousser les
petits s'enlits on parle beaucoup de ce
mouvement-là c'est une des premières
fleurs vraiment riches en pollen des
fleurs de ciboulette les abeilles les
adore elles sont vraiment friands sinon
ben il y a tellement de fleurs
différentes le tournesol le tournesol
c'est comme un buffet à volonté il peut
avoir cinq espèces d'abeilles
différentes sur une grande fleur de
tournesol et tout le monde va se nourrir
convenablement ou toutes les fines
herbes en fait sont des plantes
mellifères
il y a des plantes militaires très
résilientes comme je pense juste à
l'achillée mille-feuilles qui va même me
pousser dans les fiches industrielles
donc les très riches en hectares elle
est aussi très résistante aux
intempéries donc va vraiment pousser en
deux cracks de victimes presque donc ça
c'est une plante de choix les asclésiade
sont aussi c'est une super plante qu'on
peut faire pousser facilement toutes les
plantes qu'on considère comme des
mauvaises herbes sont souvent des très
bonnes plantes à papillons et abeilles
si je n'ai qu'un balcon si je ne vis que
dans une tour au centre-ville qu'est-ce
que je peux faire
moi je pense vraiment que chaque petit
pot parce que l'abeille Amiel elle est
quand même très endurante elle peut
aller chercher loin ses fleurs mais nos
petites abeilles solitaires nos petites
abeilles sauvages à nous elles font
souvent 100 mètres à la fois et donc
pour réussir à arriver à un espace qui
abondance fleur des fois ton petit pouce
sur ton balcon avec une fleur riche en
hectares qu'elle peut se déposer boire
pour se revigorer et continuer son
chemin jusqu'à une place plus abondante
on fait partie d'un écosystème qu'on le
veulent ou non et donc s'assurer d'avoir
un meilleur environnement pour les
abeilles c'est un merveillement pour la
biodiversité en général dont on fait
partie puis donc ajouter plus de fleurs
des soucis ajoutés un environnement plus
sain en général pour notre communauté
[Musique]